the honest truth about andrew tate okay  the second point is the whole thing  about monogamy he says when you're a  high value man you can have as many  women as you want now i agree i don't  necessarily think this is ethical or  unethical but i think it's true you see  some of the mo the richest most  successful men in the world they have  multiple women because they can now  here's the distinction and the important  point to make if all the women involved  know the truth they know the deal they  know what's going on then i think it's  fine my pushback was he was sort of  saying that you know all men are this  way i don't think he can talk all men  with the same brush i think that would  be unfair he can't speak for all men  obviously but like he also says  exceptions don't make rules so the rule  is if you're super high value you're the  man that every single woman wants then  yes you can have multiple women and the  women will be okay with that